in independent countries compatible to
Scotland where both wealthier and indeed
fairer than the UK
did we then asked the question with all
of our Resources with all of our talents
as a nation then why not Scotland
why should we not be able to match the
success of those independent countries
that are both more productive and more
equal than the UK those independent
countries they demonstrate economic
dynamism and social solidarity every
democracy of course quite rightly has
its Battle of ideas that's healthy but
what characterizes the success of many
of the countries we have looked at is
that over and above the essential cut
and thrust of daily Democratic
engagement that is often a general
consensus on what kind of nation they
are or indeed what kind of nation they
aspire to be I believe in Scotland we
have a similar General consensus a
belief in equality I believe an
opportunity a belief in community
and that we are entitled to certain
basic rights rights such as the right of
workers to take industrial action the
right to an adequate standard of living
the right to access a system of Health
Care free at the point of need
that consensus building defines my
political beliefs the idea of solidarity
and guaranteed rights for diverse groups
of individuals is of the utmost
importance to me so the paper that we
are publishing today that I am delighted
to be publishing today about creating a
modern Constitution for an independent
Scotland is about that kind of Scotland
that we want to see and ultimately the
kind of Scotland that we want to be it's
about the issues that matter the most
not least protecting the NHS in a
written Constitution and crucially it's
about people who live here
whoever they are and wherever they come
from they can help to shape that newly
independent country
we will debate our proposals in the
Scottish Parliament Parliament we will
of course engage with the public with
trade unions with businesses and many
others who make up Scottish Civic
Society today's paper is about how we
can build a better Scotland for everyone
so we can we hope that it will encourage
and indeed inform that wide ranging
debate
the vision that we are outlining in
today's paper it contrasts quite starkly
with a Westminster government which is
taking Scotland in a very different
approach a different direction one where
I'm afraid rights are not protected one
where rights are being systematically
eroded
the UK does not have a codified
constitution as we know instead it's
constitutional arrangements are based on
the principle that the Westminster
Parliament is sovereign this makes it a
global outlier amongst modern
democracies for example all member
states of the European Union have
written constitutions not having one and
relying on Westminster Supremacy has
real consequences we've spent the last
decade looking on as a UK government
undermines constitutional principle
after constitutional principle with very
little that anyone can do about
challenging them or holding them to
account that would not be possible in a
country with a codified written
Constitution that sets what the rules
are but then importantly and crucially
sets out what people can do to ensure
that governments and politicians adhere
to them
Westminster has already been able to
undermine the Devolution settlement
override decisions made by an elected
Scottish parliament in future
Westminster sovereignty of course could
even allow the UK Parliament to repeal
Devolution through nothing other than a
simple majority vote that's not an
abstract concept it's worth remembering
the UK government is already seriously
considering the repeal of the human
rights act one of the most significant
achievements of any UK parliament in the
last 30 years
so all of this raises the question why
should Scotland settle for the current
Westminster system rather than making
different choices ourselves
with Independence Scotland can embrace
the principle outlined in the claim of
right for Scotland that sovereignty lies
with the people and we can adopt a
reckoned Constitution that sets out to
protect key rights key values
governments of course come and go but
what a constitution built by the people
can do is set out and embody a set of
longer term more fundamental values
about what a country is for how it
should work a common understanding of a
nation's priorities
standard below which no government
should ever fall
and a mechanism for ensuring that these
aren't just lofty words but are
meaningful rights that put Power in the
hands of the people who live here
today's paper also sets out how we would
create a constitution it makes clear
that after a vote for Independence the
default Scottish Parliament would
legislate on an interim Constitution
after a wide process of consultation and
of Engagement this interim Constitution
would come into Force at the time of
Independence
following Independence we would then
develop a permanent Constitution through
a legally mandated Constitutional
Convention
this process will be driven by the
people once a draft Constitution has
been drawn up it will then be considered
by the Scottish Parliament but it will
only come into Force if the people of
Scotland vote for it in a referendum
in the context of the Westminster system
these proposals do sound radical we are
after all planning to involve the entire
country in discussions about fundamental
constitutional change
but when you look Beyond Westminster you
can see the Arab proposals are in line
with steps that have been taken by
Nations right across the world in the
last 20 years several countries have
directly involved their citizens in
designing or indeed amending their
constitutions the countries which have
amended their constitutions includes
Ireland include the Netherlands is just
two examples and Scotland we seek to
learn from International examples after
all a new constitution will protect and
enhance the rights of every person in
Scotland it should be designed it should
be considered and it should be approved
by as many people in Scotland as is
possible
because of that that this paper cannot
definitively see what will be in the
permanent written constitution of an
independent Scotland that's a decision
that can only be taken after
independence by the people of Scotland
but today's paper gives some ideas of
the provisions that a constitution could
include like similar documents and
nations are in the world we expect it
will set out fundamental values such as
democracy the sovereignty of the people
freedom and the rule of law it would
include Provisions to enhance equality
prevent discrimination it would describe
the role of some of our key institutions
such as Parliament the government the
courts but also contain measures on
other issues which people see as being
of fundamental significance and
importance it could for example
specifically protect the right to take
industrial action or recognize the right
it's an interests of our Island
communities or contain provisions on the
right to adequate housing the right of
communities to own land or our right as
Citizens to access health care which is
free at the point of need in the
Scottish government's view it should
also include Provisions stating very
clearly and explicitly that Scotland
will not host nuclear weapons
and many constitutions include
environmental Provisions we propose that
Scotland could protect the right to a
healthy environment could include
sections on sustainable development
tackling the climate crisis protecting
nature
as those examples help to demonstrate
the very process of creating a
constitution would be energizing it's a
document that will be created by the
people as well as for the people it will
help us think about and describe the
sort of country we want Scotland to be
and by helping to enhance and protect
important rights it will make a genuine
and significant difference to people's
lives
of course uh written Constitution is
something that will only come about when
Scotland is independent when people who
live in Scotland are taking the key
decisions about Scotland's future
we have made so much progress as a
country over these past 24 years with a
limited measure of self-government
as a country we are now facing a choice
of two futures
one that is driven by Westminster which
is taking advantage of a brexit Scotland
didn't vote for to erode our rights and
undermine our national Parliament
the alternative is for people in
Scotland to take our country's future
into our own hands to embed rights we
should all enjoy in a modern
Constitution and Build The Better
Scotland we know is possible thank you
and I'm more than happy to take
questions
lots of questions from the floor we do
have an order in which we will go with
and we'll dig that out there for me and
we'll go to call them Akai first at St
well this is something that would only
happen in an independent Scotland
so you tell us what you want to do when
you get there but you're not telling us
how you're going to get there how do you
get there
well of course our our preferred method
or preferred option for Scotland
becoming independent country is of
course that legally uh binding legally
mandated section 30 uh referendum now we
know that Westminster has continued to
deny that continued to block that and
that's why I've said repeatedly that the
only way to break that Log Jam to break
that Westminster intransigence is
through building popular support is the
popular support of the people that will
break that Log Jam and as much as I
would like to give STV and calling you
an exclusive of course you'll need to
wait till the 24th of July to wait till
Saturday when I'm speaking quite rightly
first and engaging with party members in
Dundee we will discuss the strategy on
the way forward for Independence but
I've just reiterate and re-emphasize the
point our position actually has never
changed our position is that we should
be independent through a referendum and
we have mandate after mandate after
mandate for that that it is a continual
denial from the Westminster government
that means we are going to have to use
the private people to break that in
transitions
so we have David Lockhart from
thanks first Minister and with mortgage
rates as high as they are with people in
your own party considering that
Independence doesn't feel imminent with
the s p facing internal problems is it
not
a bit indulgent at the moment to be
talking about the intricacies about a
written Constitution for an independent
Scotland and a quick supplementary for
me a big vote potential Westminster did
today on the future of Boris Johnson
former prime minister how do you hope
things play out there later on today
well on your on your first question I
know given everything that has happened
in Westminster over the last few years
this is going to be a very novel concept
but I think it's really important that
politicians make good in the promises
that they're elected on and in the
manifesto that we were elected on in
2021 of course we've made it explicitly
clear Not only would we pursue another
referendum on Independence but of course
that we would outline the vision of an
independent Scotland we would continue
that Independence prospectus that we had
been working on for a number of years I
think the second point I'd make an
answer to your question
is that the issue of Independence is
interlinked to the cost of living crisis
which is the number one issue that is
takes up my attention and undoubtedly is
a priority for the people of Scotland it
is over a decade of Westminster imposed
austerity it is a Westminster imposed
hard breaks on Scotland that we did not
vote for that has caused Untold economic
economic damage it is a Westminster
government's mini budget last year
that of course again caused economic and
causes economic Strife even though that
was not a budget passed by our nation's
Parliament so the issue of people
suffering is undoubtedly linked to the
fact that we don't have these Powers
these fiscal leavers economic levers in
our hands where we can make a better
school and that's why a written
Constitution that protects for example
an adequate standard of living it's not
abstract I think it's fundamental to
people's lives right now in terms of um
Boris Johnson I've been on the record
and said clearly I think that every
single Scottish MP must vote to sanction
Boris Johnson I think those that choose
to turn up to the vote and abstain or
indeed vote against a sanction any
Scottish story MP that does that is
betraying the people that they represent
Boris Johnson
and indeed the conservative party more
generally
have shown flagrant disregard
for rules that many of us most of us of
course adhere to and at the extreme end
of that we saw people literally missing
funerals of loved ones not being able to
say goodbye while they partied in
conservative headquarters that is a
betrayal of people's trust and any
Scottish 20mp
that is going to abstain or not vote to
sanction Boris Johnson that they are
rightly will face the Wrath of the
Scottish people at The Ballot Box I
don't do that for a minute
um do we have Sky TV I think Casey is
not here now so we'll move on to Peter
live TV
thank you first Minister
um the day before your first big
announcement on Independence as first
Minister was the day that Nicholas
sturgeon decided to break cover and
deliver an impromptu press conference on
her driveway
it also coincides with polling showing
that since her arrest that the SNP is
suffering in the polls and that you
could lose the next election to labor
her own personal popularity ratings are
plummeting
um your group response in the SMP has
been you I believe said that either you
stand by Nicola Sturgeon or you leave
the party that was what was reported you
didn't see that did you not see that no
you didn't say stand by Nicholas doesn't
leave the party okay is that your
question well I'll come back to that
um your group did publicly see that your
response to this is would be to send
Nicola sturgeon flowers I don't believe
that would be something that was
afforded to any other back bench MSP
when they found themselves in border
with the authorities
um I guess that there are many people
who are supporters of Independence are
now asking is protecting Nicola sturgeon
more of a priority for you than
protecting the party and Independence
for me I've said what I've said about
Nikola tell you my team again you and
others have asked me uh numerous
questions and on the issue of how
Nicholas treated I have I hope in my 12
weeks now as Leaders shown consistency
in terms of those involved in the police
investigation what I would say to you is
that as leader of the SNP I take with
the utmost seriousness the trust that
members have put in me to make sure that
the SNP continues to be a party that is
willing elections that is exactly the
strategy I have that exactly the
motivation I have going into any
election including of course uh the next
uh general election and in terms of
support for Independence
no doubting at all Peter the premise of
the question that these have been
difficult weeks months for the SNP I'm
not doubting that for a second in fact
there probably been some of the most
difficult months the s p has faced and
it's more than political history
despite that support for Independence is
Rock Solid many polls showing the
support for Independence has been about
50 some showing perhaps just below uh 50
but support for Independence has been
solid and therefore that's why it's so
important that we don't just point out
westminster's feelings of their of that
there are there are many but also that
what we do as I've been trying to do
today in this paper is that line of
positive vision for an independent
Scotland so for me the case for
Independence is bigger than any one
person or personality and myself
absolutely included the case for
Independence and the it is predicated on
a vision of an independent Scotland
where the powers and in the future
direction of this country are in the
hands of the people of this country
thanks Peter James
just almost been talking in Edinburgh
about ending oil and gas exploration in
the North Sea around Scotland and also
about setting up an energy company in
Scotland are you being out flanked on
climate change policy not at all let me
say that uh I'm not sure anybody will
trust a labor party on the green economy
just two weeks after they dumped their
28 billion pound green Prosperity fund
why on Earth should we trust a labor
party that and successive UK governments
has squandered not tens but hundreds of
billions of oil and gas revenue and not
invested but a fraction back into
Scotland and we should somehow be
thankful that they're going to set up a
part of a government Department if they
win a general election well look in
Scotland and as part of the Scottish
government we don't just talk the talk
we walk the walk we've got the track
record to prove it whether it's Scotland
whether it's tens of thousands of jobs
that we have created whether it's a 500
million pounds just transition fund that
we have committed so for me I don't
believe in the Scottish government has
been cleared on this we don't believe in
unlimited extraction of oil and gas we
don't believe that Scotland's future
isn't continued indefinite extraction
the the North Sea we believe that
Scotland's future is absolutely
unrenewable and green technologies and
that's why as I said we have not just
invested in the likes of the just
transition fund but of course set up for
example the Scottish national Investment
Bank which is helping to unleash some of
that Capital that's going to be required
to to boost the the green economy in the
Northeast but right across Scotland as
well
um Alan from global
thanks um just reading this stuff on
defense in this proposed Constitution
would suggest Banning nuclear weapons
from an independent Scotland just
wondering how that squares with joining
NATO who have you spoken to within the
alliance around the alliance that says
you could impose those preconditions and
still be allowed to join well remember
our wording is very careful that we
would look to remove nuclear weapons
from Scotland in a way that is in a
manner that is safe and expeditious so
we want that done as quickly as we
possibly can but safely too we are going
to be and we continue to be at this
present day and moment a responsible
Global partner and therefore we would
look to join nato in the same basis that
countries like the most recent entrance
Finland has Finland has been very clear
in its opposition to hosting and basing
nuclear weapons on its soil that would
be the same basis upon which we would
seek to join NATO what I would say is
that we would do that in a way that as I
say is safe is responsible as a global
partner so discussions of course would
take place with the UK government with
NATO and its allies on that very point
I think the other question is going to
take in the principle I think that's our
our broadcasters and uh radio and I
think we're going to do a separate so
thank you very much for coming across I
will speak to Media the members of the
print media in just a moment's time but
thank you very much for coming across
your time is greatly valued and greatly
appreciated thank you